[Applause]
covers everyone I like that big game
show wave you just gave everybody how
are you good how are you to you look
absolutely gorgeous you looked beautiful
uh last night at the Oscars you were
there I was there did you have fun at
the event was it was it a good time I
did I mean I got stoned with Franco
beforehand so you Stone now I
know no I was kidding I it just seemed
like you're having a really good time
yeah uh well okay so you had a good time
what did you do did you go to parties
afterwards I don't I have not been to
the have you been to the Oscars Andy
I've never been I've never been to the
Oscars either and I don't know what it's
like the show's over what do you do what
happens uh you have a drink you you
relax you yeah we went to the vanny fair
party then we went to another party that
was not dancing all night just great
Dance Part No cameras allowed let loose
really so can you give us a little
backstage dirt who was dancing that you
saw dance who was out on the Dance Floor
there were a lot of good uh Eva Mendes
was
dancing everyone was dancing but even
Ray feines was dancing I me it ran the
gamut from Eva to to Ray I can see you
don't think of him right Dancing Yeah
but yet Ray fines I think of as this
sort of button down very serious English
actor he was getting crazy on the floor
yeah he was cutting rug did you dance
with Ray F I did oh you did yes I did
you want to talk to us
[Laughter]
about no uh Lady Gaga yes uh said this
is interesting Lady Gaga said she's the
biggest star in the world right now she
said she wants you to play her in a
movie that's how how's that first of all
that's got to be flattering she
obviously loves you thinks you're great
it was very very cool it was shocking I
mean I didn't know she knew I was live
even so I wouldn't go crazy
there you and lives and Manelli I guess
you both were at a concert at first is
this right Lady Gaga concert she inv
well actually I was invited by her after
after she said that and I thought oh
that was really nice of her to say that
and so I sent her flowers so then she
invited me to her concert and a little
love affairs blooming very nice cool
tell us about
that this is what I do when I go in for
the today I don't know what's going on
right now that's my new technique other
people have the camera slowly push in
this is my I'm going to get to the
bottom of this oh okay is that freaking
you open book all right I often use that
on often use that women in high school
and it didn't work I really like you
keeping it up it's going to work one of
these days when in my late 60s so you
and Liza Manelli went to uh Lady Gaga
show together but yes okay and then she
called you sort of called you out on the
stage and she said is this right she
said you are badass to look up
to she said something like that yeah
this is the court transcript of what she
said it wasn't something like that I
sent lawyer to this thing and she said
bad your badass to look up to
which is such a mind-blow very cool
thing for her to say really it was
really cool you think of yourself as a
badass you know yeah yeah every
day I wake up and I say how how can I be
batter and
bitchier